I have forgotten nothing you taught me
Treat Williams has died he was 71 years
old I always knew that I wanted to work
in television because this is a chance
to spend time with my family treat's
agent confirmed the news to E.T
revealing the star lost his life after
being involved in a motorcycle accident
saying he was killed Monday afternoon he
was making a left or a right and a car
cut him off
you can ask me about going up against
and aren't you worried and and I don't
care about any of that I'm I'm making a
show I mean I'm a God get up on stage
for 15 people in a play so
I'm not up against anything we're not up
against anything we're going on the air
and and we hope some people to watch
the actor who had more than 120 credits
to his name started his career in 1975.
then found breakout success playing
Burger in the 1979 film adaptation of
the Broadway musical hair
[Music]
some fans May recognize treat from his
role as Dr Andrew Brown in the WB drama
ever would and I guess it's a great day
in the history of the Browns yes
I guess it is
I love these actors and I love these
scripts we have all the shows I've ever
been in that was a very close-knit group
of people and I just loved it I'm very
proud of that show it was a lot of fun
most recently treat appeared in the
Hallmark Channel series Chesapeake
Shores we somehow just became a family
again I'm almost by so fast the network
released a statement following his death
saying they are heartbroken and will
remember him for the joy he brought to
our screens and the Legacy he leaves
behind treat is amazing in this I'm very
grateful for Barbara being there we
really had a lot of fun too